من منا لا يحلم بان لا يكبر بالعمر ويصل
لمرحله الشيخوخه لكن ماذا لو اصبح الحلم
حقيقه اعاده والله الله يستر الفريق من
الباحثين في جامعه كاليفورنيا نجحت في
تطوير طريقه لاعطاء عمليه الشيخوخه
باستخدام ساعه وراثيه متذبذبه طبعا في
الاختبارات مشاهدينا تبين انه خلايا الخمي
ره لفتره اطول بنسبه بنسبه حوالي 82% من
الخلايا التي لا تحتوي على الخميره فلكل
خليه
ترليونات الخلايا تخضع لتغييرات جزيئيه
على مدار حياتها ويمكن ابطائها قبل ان
تموت وطبعا بما انه خلايا جسم الانسان
ليست خلايات خلايا خميره طبعا لذلك فانه
لا يزال هناك طريق طويل قبل الاحتفال
بالانتصار على الشيخوخه لذلك يدرس
الباحثون امكانيه تطبيق هذه التقنيه على
الخلايا البشريه بما يشمل الخلايا الجذعيه
والخلايا العصبيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات